لولا يعود يهتف مؤيده في العاصمه
البرازيليه التي تستعد لحفل تنصيب الزعيم
اليسري رئيسا من جديد يرفعون شعارات تصف
عودته بانه دليل على براءته من تهامي
الفساد التي سجن بسببها ثمانيه عشر شهرا
قبل ازاله الاحكام عنه وفوزه في
الانتخابات الاخيره
من ولايته شماليه البرازيل اتى بولو مع
عائلته للاحتفاء بيوم تاريخيا بالنسبه
اليه
بالسياره مع زوجه واولاده ليشاركه في
الاحتفال بالعوده الى الديمقراطيه عوده
الاولى الذي ستعود معه السعاده الى
البرازيل
رغم الاستقراب الحادي في البلاد شكل لولا
اخيرا حكومه واسعه من 37 وزيرا موزعين على
10 احزاب من اليسار والوسط تميزت بتخصيص
وزاره للسكان الاصليين للمره الاولى
سنعمل في وقت قصير لاعاده تفعيل المؤسسات
وسنقوم بجهد مضاعف من اجل البرازيليين لان
شعبنا لا يستطيع الانتظار طويلا
لم يكون علمنا احمر مجددا كان هذا تصريح
خصمه السياسي الرئيس المنتهيه ولايته جري
بلسمارو عندما تسلم الشهره الرئاسيه لكن
اللون الاحمر عاد الى العاصمه بينما غادر
برسونال البلاد ممتنعا عن تسليم تلك
الشاره لخلفه او تهنئته بالفوز للمره
الاولى في تاريخ الديمقراطيه البرازيليه
خطوه يراها توليو الخبير بشان البرازيلي
مخيبه لامال مؤيديه فرصه لخصومه مع بدايه
عهدهم
في مرحله تشهد استقطاب وانقسام حادين بعد
فوز لولا بفارق مليونير صوت فقط وخروج بون
سونار بشكل اضر بصورته امام مؤيده الفرصه
ستكون سامحه للرئيس الجديد لتوحيد
البرازيليين خلفه من اجل النجاح في مرحله
القادمه
الرئاسه اسفل الفندق الذي يقيم فيه في
العا البرازيليه التي تشهد اجراءات امنيه
مشدده واستثنائيه بالتزامن مع التحضيرات
لحفل تنصيب ضخم بمشاركه دوليه ومحليه
وشعريه واسعه
بتنصيب الرئيس الاولى دا سيلفا تبدا
البرازيل مرحله جديده مختلفه يعود فيها
اليسار الى راس سلطه التنفيذيه بعد ازاحته
عنها باسقاط اخر رئيسه الله عن طريق
البرلمان عام 2016 ليحكم مجددا من دون
حياذته اغلبيه في المجلسين التشريعيين
ايضا حسن مسعود الجزيره البرازيليه